Speaker 1: So in the midst of the FBI raid of
Donald Trump's Mar a Lago home and the right
wing going apoplectic to try to figure out
how can we attack what happened here today?
Eric Trump not known as Trump's smartest child,
but that's okay. Eric Trump goes on Fox News and
is so visibly triggered that he doesn't even
know what he's saying first, starting with
the epitome of the victimhood that the Trumps
are the biggest victims in the United States.
Speaker 2: You know, they went after
him. They went after all of us. There's
no family in American history that
has taken more arrows in the back
than the Trump family every single time. Right.
Speaker 1: If you think of families who have
been destroyed by simply having family members
imprisoned due to having drugs, if you think of
families who have lost children in mass shootings,
if you think of families who can't even afford to
feed their children. No, no, no, no, no. It
is the Trump family that has been the most
victimized of any family. Then Eric Trump pulling
everything out of the hat, bringing up Benghazi.
Speaker 2: Going back to Hillary. There's a
whole lot of other things. How about the Benghazi
scandals? How about the Clinton Foundation? I
mean, how many, you know, shady oligarchs from
Russia were contributing to that? Look, about how
about Uranium One? You want to talk about scandals
that were never investigated, never vetted. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You know, I remember was it eight? Was
it 12 investigations into Benghazi? Benghazi
was a tragedy. It was horrible what happened.
But Hillary's involvement was investigated up
and down. She testified under oath for 8 hours,
something Donald Trump has not done. Gimme a
break. Eric then goes on and says there wasn't
even anything in the safe that they ransacked.
Speaker 2: They we get another subpoena and they
do it for one reason because they don't want
Donald Trump to run and win again in 2024. And,
Sean, that's what this is about
today. Have 30 FBI agents actually
more than that descend on Mar a Lago, give
absolutely no notice, go through the gate,
start ransacking an office, ransacking
a closet. You know, they broke into a
safe. He didn't even have anything in the safe.
Speaker 1: Now, if there was nothing in the safe
that's almost more suspicious, I'd be
wondering where was the stuff moved to?
Then lastly, Eric Trump saying where are
where did these FBI agents go anyway?
Speaker 2: You know, shady deals with
everybody around the world. And by the way,
it's all on his laptop for the whole world
to see in his own writing, in his own words,
corroborated by everybody. Where are these
FBI agents? Where. Where is everybody?
Speaker 1: Why so? Eric Trump highly triggered and
making no sense at all. Let's now allow some time
to let this settle and develop. We will
learn more about it and we will see where
it ultimately goes. What I want to ask you is, do
you believe this is finally the levee breaking?
Do you believe an indictment is coming?
Let me know. Find me on Twitter at Pacman.